when arctic waters turn warmer
walruses must abandon their melting
havens in search of food and dry land
[Music]
the fate of a walrus lies in the
shifting ice
with nothing solid to rest on and long
distances to swim
a walrus can drown in a watery arctic
not far from the males females have also
been contending with a melting refuge
born less than a day ago
a pup follows his mother into arctic
water
[Music]
with no time to lose his mother gives
him a swimming lesson
[Music]
it looks like fun
but this is serious business
the females and the young will soon
begin their own journey in pursuit of
ice
[Music]
their lives depend on keeping up with
mom
[Music]
you